Before this video begins
This video is gonna be played in half the speed
So for you to watch it it properly
Hit 2x on your browser
It should work even if you're on a phone
Or if you are on a computer
this is not a desperate void for me to increase my watchtime
It's because
I NEED TO DESTROY T-SERIES!!!
I can't believe this day finally came
My own audience
My own nine year olds
Have turned against me
How could this happen?
What led this to happen?
You don't know what I'm talking about?
Well look at this
Top 10 mysteries science still can't answer!
I do not look like Bigfoot!
Frickin' stop it!
And if I had legs, then where are they?
So stoopid
I'm gonna tell Susan on you guys
You guys don't understand
Think I'm playing?
If we get this to LWIAY Felix has to say what he stole